goo
[拍手]
こんな暑い中よく来てくれたん
皆の子ごきげんよう
さてさています
ワシが今から話すコキ
どのように思ってもらっても釜を
世の中には色んな考えの者が居るようにいろんな見方
聞き方があってしかるべきだ
わしが語ることどのように受け止めてもらってもかもが
鷲尾
この場に戦をするのと同じ気持ちでたって良い
話をするはしと
話を聞くお主達
その真剣勝負戦である
勝寛分ければ
何を以てか地とするかもう一度言うぞ
わしの話をどう思ってもかまわウガー
戦である以上最後まで油断をするな
さて位
わしがはまず何者かを語ろうと思う
は支部は日の事の出雲阿国たーっと今風で言うとな
日本国島根県にある松江城から
したものだなはほんまかメジロ
10分23年生まれじゃ
わかるかっ
西暦 d
1,554円者
好機で言えば
2114年者
今年で463歳になる
ご想像の通り日ノ本の6社である
さてだった
わしが居るこの松江城
我が主堀尾吉晴公が作られた
今から
406年前じゃ
一度も思えてもなく小屋音壊れてもない
現存するしのである
このまず以上に来られる観光のお客人に
おもてなしをするのがわしのお役会
時には道案内をしたり時には写真撮影に応じたり時には
まっ正常のご説明をいたす
松井に来られるお客人にまずは楽しんでもらう
表主も最初はそこからだという思いでお城に詰めておる
おもてなしをしているとなぁ
実名色々な方々と接することになる
[音楽]
歴史好き
城好き
中にはあのなんだあの
sns とやらぬいい
タグ爛漫中のになあの写真を投稿したいがためそれだけのために来られるお客人も居る
わけだ
まあその
来る人来る人事に
思い出がそこに生まれるわけだ
松江城ができ今に至るまで
生まれた思い出の萬国の中のをほんのちょっとだがこんなことがあったと
をご説明したいと思う
何年か前じゃな
60歳ぐらいの爺さん
奥様はな買い物に出かけて行って自分が暇だから暇つぶしにこの松以上に見物に来たと
いう
で散々自分は旅慣れてる女が声である
欧州のどこぞこのお城は美しかった
絵本はダメで水フォンが小さい
もうすっかりを歌った
ゆっくり登っていってこの後ろの店主の前にそうだな
説明忘れておった
城ごとの後ろでこの頭のような建物これを店主というのじゃが
この犬種のをはへ来た時爺さ
驚いて終わった
そこでは市が重々しく
今から400年前に建てられていっ
一度も壊されていない
ここ強く言ったんじゃよ
松江城の堅守でオール
といったときその爺さん少年のように目がキラキラとして
方
そこでは下のは気分が乗ってきたなうん
というのに入っ
古くて c sanaa 白ジャイロというと爺さ
いよいよいやいやと慌てておった
この爺さん
日ノ本の城が小さいうものだと誰か送っておったのだ
栄養の良さを知って日の事の良さに気づいてなかった
芸術作品も同じこと時間にその上でみないとその良さというのは分からものだ
もう一つだけ紹介してい
これも数年前の話だ
年若い男と女が店主の前で写真を撮っていた
恋人同士が写真を撮りはこれはよくあることなんじゃ
鷲鼻最初は微笑ましく見ておったところが
これはなんか違うなと気がついた
男
1枚の写真を
手にしていっ
その姿を女が写真を撮っているわけ
お二人
姉と弟で今回来たのはこの二人の父上
父親のためだったそういう
この2人の父親若かれし頃この松江に住んでい
よく
松江城の前で撮った写真を自慢げに見せておったそうだ
イェーガー
なくなった
バネットをどうと
今度は
父が昔いたまっ正常に来て父の写真と同じように弟その場所に立たせて同じように姉が
写真を撮りに来たという理由だった
この姉と弟ぞ
まあ正常の前で撮った写真はさらに思い出に加わることであろう
もちろん
最後に
わしもこの姉御像とと一緒に記念写真を撮ったわけじゃがー
思い出にいい
思い出がさらに重なったことであろう
今回はなこの少ない事例しか紹介でき6が
かくのごとく
末裔常には年齢を問わず多くの方々が来られる彼らの人生の思い出ぬ人雲飾ったわけだ
末裔所400年前
堀尾吉晴公が作られた
者が凝りを様お一人の力で作られたわけではない
戦国時代多くのものが
平和な時代を作りたいと思い戦い
自分たちが安心して住める場所を未来につなげたいという思いでその多くの人たちの
思いが詰まった白い蛇
どれだけの人がこの400年の間この城に触れ
死後を眺めてきたか
白を中心に街を作り上げ
生活してきたか守ってきたか
仕出し
この松以上も他のお仕事同じように
いくども白が壊されそうになった
その都度幸運にも残った
清本にはかつて
今んから
3万のお城があったと言う
5万近くあったと言う学者も居る
松江だけで200のお城があったわけだ
今そのほとんどがない
人々が残そうとする尽力はもちろんあった
ジャガー
白が残った最たる理由は
申し上げれば
ウィンが良かったとしか言いようがない
建ててから壊されつ残っているテージョがある白は
今や中にしかない
たったの12弾
積である
では
壊されて
燃えてなくなったヒロは運がない
ダメな白か
答えは
いいなぁ
そんな単純な話ではない
時代の流れてどうしてもなかったらいい
時々の政権によって無用の寵物とされ
打ち壊され風呂の薪とされた城もあった
災害で損失しそのまま消えてなくなった白もあった
空襲にあって燃えてしまった白もあったどうしようもなかった
とはいえ
失われた時の人々と心の損失はいかばかりであろうか
そもそも
白は何のためにあるか
それを
大切なものを守るためにある
では何を守るか
人の命際さ
それらを守る為に存在していくのが白
そこに城があったからこそ
お主たちの先祖が生き延びて今
虫たちが生きとるわけ
石垣しか残ってないしろもある名前しか残ってないしろもある
復元した白でも指導は白じゃ
そこに城があったからこそ人の命がつないでこれたわけじゃ
虫も中身もいっぱい住んでる所にもいっぱいしちゃうだったわけじゃ
ちょうどいい女があったな
もうそこの青梅市
生まれはどこだ
まっすんだんかぁー
歩いてきたか
ようなことだなぁ増田所今でもあるか
はい者は java の石垣とか城壁はまだ
その後は残っております
てアソコを高い山じゃろう
一度登って見てごらん子供の頃一旦目線と今入った目線では必ず違う混ぜた
そしてそこになぜ汁があるのか
なぜ立てたのか
その意味がちゃんとバカなんですか私の話をちゃんと聞いてればな
油断6するなっ
おもし
う主はどこから来た
松江か
あー松江のどの辺りじゃ北か南か
あみか
南あの辺もなぁ大体一杯し大体その山陰道の始球山陰道の1水には多くの城取り入れが
あったわけじゃその方がな
どこに住んでるか細かいところを突か孤児情報だからな
だけどそこには必ず白が一つ二つあっ
そこにヒロがあったからこそ1-1無題
生き延び
今を生きているわけだ
で見事いったらそこになぜ城があったのか
ちゃんと目的があってちゃんと理由があるから使用があろう
今度会ったときもで仕方を覚えとけよ
今度会ったときまた聞くからな
いつも良いご来場の皆様一度も良い
自分たちが生まれたところ
自分たちが今住んでるところそこにあっ
かつてあったであろう城の名前ぐらいの覚えておいてほしい
は死後の
松江城を通じて
みんなに歴史に触れていただきたいと願う
よくな
歴史の勉強は年後を覚えさせられて
苦しい思いをした苦手だという声を作っ
逸見ざんねーんだ
第ないこと子が
そもそも歴史とは何のためにあるか
過去を知り
源左未来つなげるためにあるわけ
おぬし立場
より良い未来を切り開く義務がある
未来はどうなるか分からんだから予測はできる
未来は今起こっていることの積み重ねで成り立っている
今起こっていることは
過去の出来事からなれたって言う
これを忘れるでないぞ腕を
過去を知るにはどうするか
過去を生きてきた人々の記録である
歴史を知ることだ
温故知新
昔を温ねて新しき未来を測るという言葉
加工を訪ね求めることでそこから新しい地形解を導くということが説かれておる
この言葉からでも
過去や歴史を学び新しき未来を空ける
大切さがわかるであろう
書物から
死を知るも大事
ジャガー
お城のように
ゆかしから残っているものに
実際に触れ合うことで
頭だけではなく
心から
歴史を知ることができるであろう
さて a
冒頭は氏はこの場は戦であると言うた
は人の戦
どうじゃったかなどうじゃったからどうじゃったかな
どうじゃったかなあ
まだまだいうラグがするな
これからも
和紙と思う人たちの i 沢続いてくる
エンジンたちから学び
未来を作っていくという意気さである
共に
戦っていこうではないか
[拍手]